Breakneck speeds necessary this close to
the border the so-called Red Zone our
escort says a fast-moving Target is
better at avoiding Russian troops just a
few kilometers away
we arrive at a checkpoint the only one
of its kind in the country
[Music]
almost two years into the war pogrovka
is a place where people can seek
Sanctuary
hundreds use it to walk into the country
every day it's even been used for
prisoner swaps
the final stretch on the Russian side is
a No Man's Land people have to cross
alone
they find help here but also suspicion
at the edge of the country there is fear
bordering on paranoia and with good
reason
earlier this month the defense Ministry
said Sumi is the most frequently used
region by so-called Russian saboteurs to
cross into Ukraine
and even in this relatively quiet part
of the war Russian attacks our routine
soldiers ask us to leave and tell us to
stop filming we've just left the
checkpoint behind us and what we
witnessed is a real anomaly in this war
an official border crossing with Russia
that is still open to allow people to be
able to cross into Ukraine
new arrivals are taken to a nearby
Village for Security checks
a temporary shelter offers a bed a hot
meal a chance to unwind
most as always are women and children
Oksana is from kharkiv her husband
disappeared in the early days of the war
and she fled to Russia after her house
was destroyed
she's been trying to get back ever since
it's been mentally difficult for the
children they do not understand why all
this is happening
somehow we managed it was hard we were
afraid I can't even explain it to you I
just can't I just thought about what my
children would have to eat not to be
hungry and to stay safe
most of the returnees are from areas
under Russian occupation
here the work of local volunteers is
vital in reuniting Ukrainian families
this Corridor is essential because a
large number of people return through it
many people have lost their Ukrainian
documents and cannot travel through
Europe so this Corridor is a way for our
citizens to return home
Oksana hopes to join her mother soon
the whole time we were there she seemed
to be in tears exhausted by an arduous
Journey
perhaps relieved she's almost home
Zain basavi Al Jazeera at the pokerovka
border crossing in Ukraine SUNY region
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera